>>Well, one innovation that can, I think help
the world is world
governance of future.
Because you know where the U.N. and other
organizations propose to
whole countries to prove foods but there is
not any regulation or any
good management.
And we are organizing in Dakar, Senegal, in
May, next March or May, the
world conference on the governance in the
future in the world.
About energy, my, my proposal in Copenhagen
was to turn to sort of
energy.
Because you know the world tried all forms
of energy.
The wind, the water, and the [INAUDIBLE] petrol
now energy.
These all form are very big improvement but
we call the proper energy.
And we think that we can create in factory,
energy factory, that
provide the all of the energy we need for
the 20 next years and the
amount of the capacity is about 100,000 mega
watts.
We can do it.
I would say.
And now France is building a factory for their
energy, and German also.
And as a cost of China to create some energy
to the health of the
[INAUDIBLE] anyway, I am proposing after that
to turn to sort of
energy.
About the environment, about environment,
I think one possible problem
is the desert.
The desert is advancing to destroy the Savanna
and the forests.
So we have a very big problem what we call
Great Green Wall.
The Great Green Wall a wall of trees 15-meter
large on 7,000 kilometers
from Dakar to Jabuti.
And we have started to build our part in Senegal.
That means we have presently on 500,000 kilometers.
And this project is supported by the whole
international community,
European Union and the other countries.
Until now there is anything very significant
as the contribution to the
construction of this wall that is very important
for all humanity.
Only France has send soldiers with plenty
of trees in the wall, Great
Green Wall.
You talk about financial problem.
I stated that the financial pieces cannot
find the solution in the
countries, but in Africa we called all our
capacity for [INAUDIBLE] to
invest in the rail production.
About Haiti, I would say that I stated that
the highest of the duty to
return to Africa because they are transplanted,
they are ancestors was
transplanted by force, by slavery system and
Senegal have a particular
relationship with Haiti.
And many Haitians live in Senegal.
In general, [INAUDIBLE] that an southwesters
come from 16 gal.
So I have stated that.
So if I can ask to any country, citizenship
you should grant them for
that.
I think they have the right.
The other question is how is if the government
of Haiti and the people
of Haiti think that they want to come back
to Africa.
We should recognize them for this duty and
help them as they did for
Liberia one century before.
At the beginning, they were a problem between
the natives and the
African-Americans who came from the United
States but now there is very
integration though this people and only the
citizens of Liberia.